so jamie i wanted to start with you on
this one
this isn't your first go-around with a
movie that involves
super powers so what was it about the
project power script that made you think
it was worth
jumping back into the genre for this the
human side of it it's like when you look
at
uh art's character who i i play a guy
who's
trying to hunt down this drug that when
you take it it gives you five
minutes of super powers but also
uh i found out uh as i
run into this incredible light of of
power herself
and energy and talent uh dominique
fishbach
who plays robin and we sort of come
together
uh to on this incredible journey
um it's the human side of it first
the way we connect that we both need to
get something out of life
she's trying to figure out a way out and
i'm trying to figure out a way out of
something bad and then once we come
together
and you see that chemistry now
everything else makes sense you know all
of the
the the the fire and the brimstone of
the movie makes sense because of
of how we connected as as the humans
dominique i always find that your first
big gigs
usually leave an impression so looking
back
on night comes on is there anything that
you took from your experience
working with jordana on that movie that
you find still coming in handy today
even on a big movie like project power
night comes on was my
first opportunity to like be a lead to
carry a movie and be on set every single
day
that the crew was there it was something
that i felt like i could do
in my spirit but to get the opportunity
to do it really
uh just showed how much sometimes you
need to get the opportunity to really
believe it you can believe in yourself
but it doesn't really set in until you
get to do it
so um getting to do night comes on and
then just like
elevating that with project power
because of the fact that
it wasn't only just like it was four
months not 30 days
you know and then it was it was all
through the night and there was
different elements it was the rain and
the
the
stunts and all these things and then uh
the fact that i got to do it with jamie
foxx and joseph gordon-levitt just
really um it's it's really surreal
i also wanted to revisit something you
told me at the hate u give junket
when you could see george doing his
monitor dance when he sees that
something's really working
on set so for project power
what do ariel and henry do behind the
monitor when they see
something working do they have their own
monitor dance hmm
i don't know if they hadn't monitored
this but uh they were
uh well they were really playful
and so rel kind of did this thing where
you like i started doing this thing
where i would kind of fish him like
i would do this thing where i throw a
fishing rod and then it would catch his
it would catch his lip
and then he would fall and he'd be
pulled over um henry
like pulled over him um so yeah it was
a little stuff like that where the
moment where it was a little bit more
calm and we got to
play and have fun and then jamie and and
henry and rel were
juggling at one point i was thoroughly
impressed they were all three just
just doing it yes to wrap up here i
have a feeling you're gonna get asked a
lot about your dream
power that you would want the pill to
unlock so instead of that
what is the most boring but practical
superpower that you
actually wish you had i would be captain
wi-fi
oh captain weepy i have no wi-fi because
we lost power today so that was going to
be my answer because of this whole
experience doing junkets on one bar on
my phone
oh man you're getting it though you got
it thanks so much for talking with me
again and
huge congratulations on another movie
thank you